or call 1-877-866-8555.
>> Greg: THIS WEEKEND, WE
LEARNED TWO IMPORTANT THINGS
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE AND THE
MEDIA, JOE’S FAVORITE FLAVOR OF
ICE CREAM.
>> BEFORE THE PRESIDENT WAS
INAUGURATED, I DID ASK HIM FOR
MY 4-YEAR-OLD WHO WAS VERY
CURIOUS, THAT IS MY UPDATE FOR
ALL OF YOU.
>> Greg: AMAZING.
WE ALSO LEARNED WHAT HUNTER
BIDEN HAD FOR BREAKFAST, BAGELS.
CAN’T WAIT FOR THE DAILY REPORT
ON REGULARITY.
I HOPE THEY’RE BOTH GETTING
ENOUGH FIBER.
BUT ISN’T IT ADORABLE HOW FAST
AND OBVIOUS THE MEDIA CAN CHANGE
THE RULES?
NO STRANGER TO ICE CREAM OR
BAGELS, CNN’S BRIAN SALTER ASKED
THIS QUESTION.
AS PRESIDENT BIDEN MAKING NEWS
BORING THEN?
THEIR ANSWER IS NO, YOU ARE.
UNLESS YOU THINK NEWS IS YOUR
LATEST COMPLEMENTARY CLICHE.
AFTER A WEEK IN WHICH WE SAW THE
WHITE HOUSE BANISHED THE
NATIONAL GUARD TO A PARKING LOT,
THE OBLIVIOUSNESS TOWARDS THE NT
FIVE RIOTS, THE LIES ABOUT TRUMP
NOT LEAVING A VACCINE PLAN, A
MORATORIUM ON NATURAL GAS AND
DRILLING.
INSTEAD, WE GET ICE CREAM AND
BAGELS.
THE IDEA THAT SOMEHOW THE NEWS
GOT BORING IS ONLY TRUE ONCE YOU
REALIZE WHAT CNN WAS OBSESSED
WITH BEFORE.
TWEETS, GOSSIP, TANTRUMS,
TELL-ALL BOOKS AND OF COURSE
THOSE ATTACKS ON CNN BUT ALL IS
GONE WITH DRUM AND WHAT THEY
CHOSE TO IGNORE IN FAVOR OF THAT
DRIVEL WERE MONTHS OF RIOTING
AND LOOTING BECAUSE THAT WOULD
MAKE THE DEMOCRATS LOOK BAD.
THEY MOCK THOSE WHO WERE
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT STUFF.
MEANWHILE, THEY IGNORED STUFF
THAT WOULD’VE REELECTED TRUMP
LIKE THOSE MIDDLE EAST PEACE
PLANS AND AMAZING VACCINES BUT
THINGS ARE BORING NOW RATED AS
12,000 MORE AMERICANS DIE FROM
COVID, REMEMBER HOW NOT BORING
SUCH NUMBERS WERE UNDER TRUMP?
WHEN THE DEMOCRATS IN CHARGE,
THE BODY COUNT SUDDENLY BECOMES
REASONABLE JUST LIKE EVERYTHING
ELSE UNDER THEIR WATCH.
SO I HAVE A FEELING THAT IF
TRUMP WAS EATING ICE CREAM, THEY
WOULD FOCUS ON THE UNHEALTHY
LIFESTYLE AND SAY HOW FAT HE IS
BUT HERE, JOE BIDEN’S FAVORITE
PLAYER, YOU WOULD SHE WAS YOUR
GRANDDAD.
>> Dagen: THEY CODDLE
JOE BIDEN LIKE HE WAS SOME
SEPTUAGENARIAN INFANT TO GET
THEM ELECTED LIKE BENJAMIN
BUTTON SO NOW THAT HE IS
PRESIDENT BENJAMIN BUTTON, THEY
HAVE TO KEEP UP THIS ACT FOR THE
NEXT FOUR YEARS.
THEY HAVE TO COVER FOR HIM.
PROTECT HIM, ACT LIKE NOTHING
WAS WRONG DESPITE THE FACT THAT
HE IS IN LESS THAN A WEEK AND
TAKEN GREAT STEPS TO DESTROY OUR
ENERGY INDEPENDENCE IN THIS
COUNTRY, KEYSTONE PIPELINE GONE,
10,000 JOBS GONE, BECAUSE GOING
UP BECAUSE OF THE PARENTS
CLIMATE ACCORD WITH US REJOINING
IT AND THIS MORATORIUM DRILLING
ON FEDERAL LAND, THANK YOU
NEW MEXICO.
SORRY WE DESTROYED YOUR DRILLING
IN YOUR ECONOMY, BUT I THINK
THAT THE MEDIA ALL ALONG LOVED
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
WE TALKED ABOUT THIS BECAUSE
THEY BECAME THE STORY.
THESE PREENING PEACOCKS LIKE
NOTHING MORE THAN TALKING ABOUT
THEMSELVES AND WE ARE UNDER
ATTACK, WORDS HURT US.
IT WAS PURE HEROISM FOR FOUR
YEARS UNDER TRUMP, WAS IN IT?
>> IT WAS.
I DO FIND IT INTERESTING THAT
THEY WERE ABLE TO FIND OUT WHAT
HUNTER WAS HAVING FOR BREAKFAST
AND LESS INTERESTED IN FINDING
OUT WHAT HE WAS DOING WITH THESE
FOREIGN POWERS TRYING TO GET
MONEY FOR HIS DAD BUT THEY KNOW
ABOUT THE BAGEL.
THERE’S A HOLE IN THAT STORY.
>> Juan: I GOT YOU, THAT’S
PRETTY GOOD, THANKS, GREG.
I MUST SAY, I’M WONDERING WHAT’S
GOING ON WITH THIS KIND OF FOCUS
BECAUSE TO ME, ARE REPUBLICANS
ALL OF A SUDDEN SNOWFLAKES THAT
THINK DEMOCRATS LOVE THE WAY
THEY ARE COVERED BY THE MEDIA?
GO TALK TO BARACK OBAMA, GO TALK
TO BILL CLINTON AND YOU CAN SEE
PEOPLE WHO BECOME PURPLE WITH
RAGE AT THE WAY THEY WERE
COVERED.
GO TALK TO HILLARY CLINTON AND
SHE WILL TELL YOU ABOUT A VAST
RIGHT-WING CONSPIRACY INCLUDING
CONSERVATIVE MEDIA HACKING HER
RELENTLESSLY AND DRIVING
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" AND OTHERS
TO DO THE SAME.
ALL POLITICIANS SEE THE
REPORTERS IS IRRITATING AND
ALWAYS LOOKING FOR THE NEGATIVE
STORY SO TO ME, PART OF THE
PROBLEM AS I SAID LAST WEEK AS
TRUMP CAME OUT OF THE BOX SAYING
THINGS LIKE MY INAUGURAL CROWD
IS BIGGER THAN EVER.
IF YOU STEP IN IT, PEOPLE WILL
SAY YOU STEPPED IN IT.
I DON’T THINK THAT’S THE PRESS
PICKING ON HIM AND IN THIS CASE
WITH BIDEN, I THINK WHAT YOU’RE
SEEING IS A LOT OF PEOPLE
REFLECTING NATIONAL SENTIMENT
WHICH IS GIVE THIS GUY A CHANCE.
THERE’S ENOUGH GOING TO BE SAID
ABOUT HIM AND ABOUT THE
DIFFICULTY IN DEALING WITH THE
REPUBLICANS IN CONGRESS GETTING
ANYTHING ACTUALLY DONE, I THINK
ALL OF US WANT THE BEST FOR
AMERICA AT THIS POINT.
>> Greg: SO SAYING WE SHOULD
GIVE JOE BIDEN A CHANCE THE WAY
THEY GAVE TRUMP A CHANCE, BUT I
DO NOTICE THE WAY THEY ARE
REPORTING COVID DEATHS IS A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT UNDER JOE
THAN UNDER TRUMP.
MAYBE THAT’S ME.
>> Jesse: OF THE MEDIA TREATED
BIDEN LIKE THEY TREATED DRUM,
THEY WOULD’VE GONE TO THE BAGEL
SHOP AND FOUND OUT IT’S AN
ILLEGAL BAGEL, THERE’S A HUGE
DIFFERENCE.
BARACK OBAMA CALLED THE MEDIA
HIS BASE, LET’S REMEMBER THAT.
HE WAS ONLY UPSET BECAUSE THEY
WEREN’T COVERING HIM LIKE A GOD
ENOUGH.
WHATEVER PRESIDENT FOLLOW
JOE BIDEN WAS GOING TO BE --
WHATEVER PRESIDENT FOLLOW TRUMP
WAS GOING TO BE BORING.
IT’S LIKE THE FOLLOWING AND
ROSES GREAT I’M SORRY.
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO THE BAR INTO
THE BATHROOM.
RIGHT NOW, YOU CAN TELL THE
MEDIA’S ALREADY BORED OF JOE
THAN THEY ARE TRYING TO MAKE THE
MUNDANE SCINTILLATING LIKE THE
BAGELS ON THE DOGS AND THE
ICE CREAM AND STUFF LIKE THAT,
BUT THAT ONLY WORKS IF IT’S A
ROCK STAR PRESIDENT LIKE A
CELEBRITY LIKE DONALD TRUMP OR
THE FIRST BLACK PRESIDENT, THAT
DOESN’T WORK WITH JOE BIDEN.
YOU CAN SANDWICH JAY LENO AND
LADY GAGA IN BETWEEN JOE BUT
IT’S STILL SLEEPY SANDWICH.
THERE’S NO GETTING AROUND THAT,
YOU CAN’T MAKE THIS GUY
INTERESTING.
SO THEY CAN’T COVER HIM IF IT’S
A SCANDAL BECAUSE THEY’RE ON HIS
SIDE AND HELPED GET HIM ELECTED
AND THEY CAN’T COVER PERSONALITY
BECAUSE THERE IS NO PERSONALITY
WITH THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION,
SO THEY’RE HAVING TO COVER
POLICY AND THAT SPELLS DOOM FOR
JOE BIDEN BECAUSE HIS POLICIES
ARE DUMB AND BAD, SO THERE ONLY
THING THEY’RE GOING TO HAVE TO
DO IF HE BOMBS SOMEONE, THEN
THEY’LL PICK UP AND START
COVERING SOMETHING.
>> Greg: THERE WERE TWO THINGS
THEY ARE GIVING HIM A PASS THIS
WEEK.
REMEMBER WHEN HE SAID HE HAD A
SOLUTION FOR THE PANDEMIC AND
NOW HE ADMITS THERE’S NOTHING WE
CAN DO AND THEN A TRAVEL BAN FOR
PEOPLE FROM SOUTH AFRICA WHICH
WOULD STRIKE THE MEDIA AND
XENOPHOBIC IF IT WERE SOMEONE
ELSE DOING IT.
IF >> Dana: JOE BIDEN SOUNDS
BORING, BUT HIS POLICIES ARE
ACTUALLY KIND OF EXTREME IF YOU
GO TO THE EXECUTIVE ORDERS.
IF PRESIDENT TRUMP PERSONALITY
WAS EXTREME, BUT HIS POLICIES
WERE ACTUALLY IN SOME CASES
LEANING RIGHT CONVENTIONAL.
>> Greg: THAT IS GENIUS!
THAT COMPARISON IS GENIUS!
>> Dana: REALLY, OR ARE YOU
MAKING FUN OF ME?
>> Greg: WHAT YOU JUST DID WAS
SHOWN THE INVERSE WHICH I HADN’T
THOUGHT OF WAS BIDEN’S BORING
BUT EXTREME AND TRUMP WAS
EXTREME BUT ACTUALLY KIND OF
BENIGN.
>> Dana: TWO EXAMPLES I WOULD
GIVE, THAT >> Dagen: ALREADY
MENTIONED, THE PIPELINE BUT
THERE WERE TWO OTHERS IN THESE
EXECUTIVE ORDERS THAT REALLY
AFFECTS PEOPLE AT HOME.
ONE OF THEM IS ENDING THE PRICE
FREEZE ON INSULIN THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD PUT INTO
PLACE AND WITH NO EXPLANATION.
I’M SIGNING THIS HERE, AND THEN
THE OTHER ONE IS ABOUT WHAT WILL
HAPPEN TO GROW SPORTS ALL ACROSS
AMERICA, THAT’S A BIG DEAL.
SO I DO THINK IT’S NOT BORING,
BEING AT THE WHITE HOUSE IS NOT
BORING BUT THEY ALSO FOCUS WAY
TOO MUCH ON THE WHITE HOUSE
ITSELF AND NOT ENOUGH ON THE
ENTIRE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
THAT IS WHERE A LOT OF BIG